et sinon les fringues ça marche on
s'attend à toi sois gentil putois c'est
mon fils il est barré ans il est barré
ans dans le tarmac
ah oui mais alors il est barré en inde
pendant un mois et demi là il est revenu
avec un cadeau mais en extra que ce truc
génial ça oui j'adore ça mais il paraît
que je sens bien je nage dont on a une
inflexion papa non je n'aurais pas dit
ça brasse ici à la dame khady juste
avant que tu arrives richard houis si si
oui mais sur et cravate la wii avec
jacques chabrun xining bon alors richard
on a fait une petite interview comme
c'est yan tu peux pas me caractériel
puisque atteint 8,6 alors attention là
parce que pendant le jingle vous avez
l'habitude des garçons en bouge pas il
faut pas bouger
bougez chanel rouge cameron il fallait
retenir tout tout tout tout ça mais non
c'est dur c'est cette émission est un
peu dur dès la 6ème minute à la
respiration des invités me le disent
souvent un petit richard hannon m'avait
dit que ce genre de blague
non ici on venait me voir l'an 2100
râpées ou ne sera pas bon alors
richard bohringer vous êtes prêts ouais
alors interview psy donc un est-ce que
vous avez des toc c'est à dire des tous
des troubles obsessionnels compulsifs
sergent vous remontez fermer le gaz de
l'eure voulait fermer oui oui oui
attention parce qu'on a eu toutes les
lapins bricier déclaré fu peas et oui ça
sera plus la baisse de 26,5 en informer
le sanglant mené par hanu est ce que
vous êtes schizo oui est ce que vous
êtes salle d'eau non attendez pas ça ne
vous aimez pas faire mal non même temps
c'est le bout des seins n'ont même pas
passé je n'ai pas moi je suis là aussi
pour faire plaisir
oui tomber si ça fait plaisir de danser
debout nous sommes ça fait plaisir j'ai
tout mais je suis pas sado-maso il ya
des filles alors est ce que vous êtes
exhibo non vous vous baladez pas à poil
dans la plaine avec la voisine qui non
non non il n'y a pas de wasit scato non
alors jusqu'à thonon travelo non tu dis
rien butin
et la roue non je ne suis pas bon est ce
que vous êtes
hypo est-ce que tu as une fois go ça
pouvait faire partie du quai salvette
est ce que vous êtes fou il est ce que
vous êtes hydrophobe je ne sais pas ce
que ça veut dire
bordeaux ni drôle au globe j'aime pas
j'aime pas l'eau à j'aime là aussi vous
aimez l'orangé bleue non ici
ouais là mais je ne bougeais nikto fob
je me rassure tout de suite ça minable
je ne cherchais pas un truc
niki lauda ça veut dire quoi votre
avenir
la phobie nique non non ça c'est porno
fob jesse voorn octobre
non ouais donc nikto fob annoncé des
gens qui ont peur de la nuit tout
simplement trop fort non non est ce que
vous êtes benno non baîllonné fob oui
alors c'est l'acteur de bruno bellone
n'enrichit quelqu'un j'ai l'habitude re
ah non non pas du tout et pour terminer
est ce que vous êtes à nemo fob non
c'est pas le mec qui aime pas les
monnaies les mots pop c'est le mec un
pâle vent ah non moi j'aime j'adore le
mans alors ce moment vous avez été
fermés
y apporte aux flambeaux ce que j'avais
appris avec manteau fox et celui qui
aime les bons tours voilà lancée suite à
tort de tous à la première fois au sénat
aurait d'ailleurs on va voir ce mardi à
progresser ses vacances en thaïlande a
prié les caresses dans les massages thaï
oui non j'ai pas pris vous marierai
jamais les copains qui vient aussi d et
n'ont pas voulu vous raconter bons amis
sont allés faire des cobayes en
thaïlande dont j'avais avant d'être avec
elle toute façon bon je vous laisse dans
les mânes linda alors là attention donc
c'est la gadoue jeu drôle à l'état
attention attention
richard si vous étiez une femme à qui
aimeriez vous ressemblez femmes
élégante avec elle pendant 30 à ce
qu'elle sera bouffantes haas all ages
écouter quitte à vous décevoir ses
basiques mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que tout ça je fais oui je fais ce
qu'il fait plaisir et donc si vous étiez
cette femme à la vôtre quelle serait sa
serait pas votre pire cauchemar
si vous deviez vivre avec richard
bohringer ben c'est de vivre aiguë c'est
vrai qu'elles allouent tyrant faire
partir tous les deux sur une île déserte
programme à leur imam
mais il a fait des choix et 1000 désert
vraiment désert oui ça veut dire
personne d'autre ça veut dire personne
très bon livre pas ça pour la prendre
c'est peut être tous les deux au milieu
des autres
vous avez dit un jour la générosité des
hommes s'arrête là où commence celle des
femmes pour nous expliquer parce que je
trouve plus généreuse que nous quoi
là il s'est mis tous les gonzesses dans
la poche en deux heures bastien boyer
d'autres trucs moins plaisant vainqueur
n'a pas de poste chanson fut georges
wolinski arts a dit un jour ça c'est
pour notre dernière question les hommes
adorent l'école c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
tout fait pendant des siècles pour
qu'elle le reste
c'est très joli mais c'est un mot sa
moue très spirituelle mais non sur le
fond on peut pas deviner
merci je pense que vous l'avez l'idée
c'était de le déstabiliser en
déstabilisant car elle